our councils started to review our
planning enforcement procedures in 2019
with the main aim of enhancing customer
experience
we also wanted to improve efficiency and
performance
and subsequently formed a framework of
tasks for officers to help achieve this
we have undertaken a thorough review of
our planning enforcement process
from receipt of customer report to
completion to help identify
strengths and weaknesses this has also
included an evaluation of case
management
specialized software was used to map out
the planning enforcement lifecycle
this enabled us to exclude unnecessary
steps
improving efficiency and resulting in a
better customer experience
to build on this further we incorporated
markers for customer contact into the
process
ensuring the team provided regular
updates to customers
as reports progressed case management
task triggers were also created to aid
performance and efficiency
we then consulted with councillors and
other stakeholders on the proposed
improvements
to ensure that these best met the needs
of customers in our districts
changes to procedures have paved the way
for ongoing
improvements in speed efficiency and
handling of a planning enforcement
report from
start to finish we have seen significant
results to date
and the process continues to evolve
meeting our aim to provide a
customer-centric service
that delivers the desired outcomes
our customers have already benefited
from a more efficient service
last year we achieved a reduction of 23
per cent in the number of cases
that have been ongoing for longer than
six months
we hope to see a bigger decrease this
year following the implementation of
software to assist
officers in managing cases according to
stated time scales
and customer expectations
a business intelligence application
crystal reports
has also been introduced to aid case
management and
monitoring this is currently used by
other colleagues in the planning team
and has proved very successful so far
we are confident that the changes to our
procedures have already
increased performance and efficiency
however
our councils remain committed to
continually improving our planning
enforcement service
and customer experience to enable us to
do this
we will undertake regular reviews of our
processes
assessing effectiveness and implementing
further improvements if required
you